let's move on texting another guy while
on vacation
what's wrong with these men god i mean
what is wrong with these men
come on
grow some cojones people come on listen
they have said for years that
testosterone rates in males are
plummeting and this is what you get this
is what you get low t it sounds like low
tea i don't know if you have low tea but
this is what it looks like it's all
those damn plastics
that's exactly right it's the plastic it
is it is among other things from big
pharma we're not going to talk about
today anyway
texting another guy while on vacation my
girlfriend and i are currently on
vacation in arizona he's writing on
reddit from the vacation
he's in the other room she's doing
whatever and he's like let me get on
reddit i don't know what to do about
this let me figure
honestly though you didn't have a friend
to call that's weird to me too your
first thought was like let me go on
reddit see what this bunch of strangers
say about what's going on in arizona
he's in arizona they've been there for
two days he says she's been texting her
former college classmate oh
i arranged this trip for the both of us
to get some alone time before i head off
to college and i feel very disrespected
oh so he's young okay he's a baby give a
slight pass to this slight
my dad's at home like no
when i was in high school i was already
acting like a man i know dad what you're
saying this guy's 23.
he's 23 23 he's not 17. i thought he was
going he's not eight i thought he was
going to
college proper age but like you know at
the age when most people go off to
college right okay he's 23. never mind
take that back he's an adult
okay i arranged this trip blah blah blah
i feel very i'm not texting anyone he
says i made a point of telling my
friends i'll be on vacay as he should
i'm on vacay with my girl don't be
bugging me up hitting up my phone 24
hours a day i don't have time i'll reach
out when i can but here she is
constantly texting him should i confront
her about this
reddit
i don't want to ruin our trip but honey
she already ruined the trip she's in the
other room you're in arizona and she's
texting her old classmate
you're worried you're gonna ruin the
trip by bringing it up no better to have
it fester in you
make you sick make you hostile toward
her then she reads that gets hostile
toward you the whole trip is why don't
you just sit her down and say hey babe
what are you doing on your phone this
whole time put the like what are you
doing why are you talking to that guy 24
7 would you rather he be on the vacation
because i can buy my trip home i can get
myself a ticket and we can fly him out
here and you guys can have a great time
i'm tired of this
guys listen can i give you a tip
how do i say this
confront women as if you're cool to just
head out
you see that attitude i just gave
hey listen you're talking to your
college client this do you hear the tone
of my voice hey i noticed you're talking
to your old college classmate a lot yeah
well papa all right well you know what i
made this trip for us for you and i to
hang out and i'm here and i told my
buddies and my friends to give us some
time you seem to not want the same thing
would you would you rather have him come
out you guys can spend a great couple of
days together and i'll head out because
i got other stuff that i could be doing
does that work for you you want me to
figure out maybe i can help set that up
do you hear the tone she'll be like
by the time you're done with that and
you go to take a shower and you're just
cool calm collected she'll be twitching
and she should be because this is
disrespectful
instead what guys do is they panic right
for some reason you panic in moments
like this
and you're like
so much so that you're on reddit
come on
and why are all these guys afraid to
bring it up to their to their
girlfriends are you that
are you dating like
way out of your like something's going
on you dating way out of your league and
you're afraid they're gonna leave you
and honestly you need this
how much out of your league could
somebody be to be worth this type of
stress zero
zero
you wonder how far this stretches into
other parts of their life you know like
my boss kicks me just kicks me a little
bit harder every day and i don't want to
be confrontational about it but enough
is enough like g's right like is it just
are they like personalities that don't
confront any type of problem right
they keep working me five hours more a
week you know and it just keeps piling
on and i don't want to ask for a raise i
don't want to go ask to go home but you
know at some point enough is it's like
dude well that's true like if you're not
standing up for yourself in this area of
life
see the assumptions that are being made
about you now which is fair is he not
standing up for himself in any area of
life i mean it's kind of a pathetic look
honestly it is you've got to stand up
for yourself
this is not by the way can i just tell
you guys this is not an attractive look
for men it's not attractive to be
pathetic it's not attractive to be a
doormat it's not attractive to tolerate
your girlfriend texting some other guy
and you don't do anything or your
girlfriend go to the movies with some
other what's she doing go to the movies
with some other guy
what does she do you don't even know him
that is batshit crazy it's not
attractive for you to sit by and allow
it that's not you being a good oh i'm
trying to be respectful no that's not
what you're doing now is tolerating
disrespect and sitting back like a
coward not attractive
she's not now she didn't want to sleep
with you before for some reason now she
really doesn't
now she really doesn't
really
go in there and give some type of
ultimatum not like you can't do this
this is don't see malt just be like hey
listen i don't need to be here i got
other things i could be doing you don't
want to be here okay somebody i know
somebody else who would enjoy this trip
i'm out
cool
nothing rattles somebody else else's
feathers like you being cool just saying
if you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]